old and moi je donne alors tu l'as déjà
dit tu as choisi d'arrêter l'école
non non c'est vrai qu'on finit par
correspond par correspondance exactement
mais tu continues à prendre des cours à
domicile parce que j'adore ça tombe bien
parce que j'ai toujours rêvé d'être prof
à domicile et je propose qu'on regarde
un point sur le programme scolaire avec
les connecteurs puisque je te le dis je
les soupçonne de ne pas avoir le niveau
scène pour ça que vous allez chez chacun
joué votre tour à votre plus chacun font
face à face avec une question de
rapidité à face à wajid ok pour la
première question c'est une question
histoire c'est facile c'est de la
rapidité des face à isabelle normalement
ça devrait pas poser de problème
wales haine contre isa isabelle vous
allez être un petit peu avantagé parce
que la question concerne votre premier
grand amour
on la verra bien sûr monbalen série a
dont vous balancer quant à nancy qui fut
le roi des francs de 480 à 500 aux
droits des fronts clovis
[Applaudissements]
bien malgré elles sont pas non merci
mais alors décalage horaire là attention
benjamin castaldi face à wade n question
chimie notamment c'est que vous êtes un
expert en gaz
oui hein à ce propos quelle est la
formule chimique du méthane un cache pas
pas évident ch4 très bonne réponse
[Applaudissements]
donnée n'a pas de nom de roger h/24 h 4
attendu janvier le bout de mon cul ouais
ouais et d'experts comptables balles et
les ménages y compris chaque jour vous
nous épater davantage avec le brushing
mais conjuguer le verbe épaté wesh des
années valérie à la deuxième personne du
pluriel du subjonctif imparfait fallait
que tu m'épates alors deuxième personne
déloyale je suis blanc qui temporel que
vous ne les connaissiez vous mais parce
que vous êtes papa sied mieux vous et
papiers
[Applaudissements]
attention pas question science on sait
que vous avez un rapport particulier
bernard montiel avec le soleil qui vous
fait environ 365 le soleil et une
étoiles âgées de combien d'années plus
ou moins qu isabelle mais combien
d'années a comme un damné tu dis
j'utilise des vas-y 4,5 milliards
d'années
john tu prends des cours à domicile
c'est son nom a fait dix ans qu'on n'a
pas
elle reconnaît ben oui elle le connaît
pas si vous vous travaillez pas l'école
c'est pas le cas deviennent si vous êtes
nuls dans dégoûté par les autres gens me
oui on sait que vous êtes capable de
repérer à corps féminin dans un rayon de
150 km
quelle est la formule pour calculer le
rayon d'un certes ça s'est passé et on
encercle mapipi 14 fois nancy 14 cd sous
doués à la télé les sous-doués isabelle
est mort de rien le dia merck dans le
diamètre du ciac / le très bon
[Applaudissements]
géraldine maillet oui géraldine mallet
elles sont les deux couleurs quels sont
les deux couleurs qu'il faut mélanger
pour obtenir du verne à ces questions
rapidité à la mise au ban des nations ça
fait un point pour l'équipe et pour
l'instant cinq points pour mettre au
monde
attention nathalie m
anat vous qui êtes la lys france de
notre plateau mais j'ai comme
jean-pierre j'ai pas eu le bac vous
inquiétez pas vous avez failli battre
mais ici nous aide dans le haut de page
ici vous avez défendu fièrement les
couleurs de notre pays qui a composé la
marseillaise webzen contre nathalie
marquay marseillaise ménages est de
l'île
attention les chéris ça va se jouer
maintenant je suis obligé de jouer
contre vous achetez voit la réponse
n'avait pas d'oreillette alors j'enlève
l'oréal c'est bien un acte courageux des
noms va jouer la contrôler y'a pas la
réponse sur affiches sont une question
mathématique ce que vous savez que je
suis expert en mathématiques
le résultat de l'opération
cinq puissances trois combats +1000 17 x
9 + 38 à diviser par 10 secondes
si l'aca alors laissez-moi concentré
well done excusez moi on va attendre
deux minutes puisque je vous coupe on me
dit que le président de la république va
faire une allocution
on verra ça après justin
françaises français mes chers
compatriotes depuis le premier jour de
la crise notre mobilisation est totale
quoi qu'il en coûte tel est l engagement
que j'avais pris devant vous dès le mois
de mars chômage partiel prêts aux
entreprises
accompagnement des commerçants des
indépendants soutien des plus précaires
tout a été mise en oeuvre par le
gouvernement est important ce cas
portons le fer au monde à moi je vais
dire 548 voilà
[Applaudissements]